during a baseball game between the  Kansas City Royals and the st. Louis  Cardinals a cat ran onto the field  yeah and equipped with it went viral and  this is one of those just silly things  takes your mind off all the depressing  stuff I thought I'd show it here it is  in case you missed it  [Applause]  yeah he hasn't man if you've had cats I  got three of them right now you can't  run with a cat now that guy from the  field crew really takes his job  seriously and it's even more impressive  when you see the footage of him after he  left the field a little later on take a  look  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  he join us tonight let's give the field  crewmember a hand  we have a great show tonight  from the ABC series blackish Tracee  Ellis Ross - TV star Chris Gethard show  Chris Gethard  we need Walker Perez is on the program  [Applause]  [Music]  you  you